here I work this all out and I had a
wonderful presentation I was noticing
and I sat down last week - time to say
and then I realized that I had made what
I consider some interesting readings
it's a very dull dishwater so what I
want to do today is to open it up a bit
the transformation and then pose a
problem if this is the case for oral
history the way we talk about it today
how can we begin to analyze how can we
begin to talk about the kinds of
problems that are raised by the
transformation that has taken place in
oral history and then proceed to talk
about oral history so Chandra obviously
relying upon the work of my dear friend
senator Shelley but but it does pose for
us the transformation and I've described
that transformation as a transformation
from a concern for data to a concern
with the text that when I began for
history what not concern was was to
recreate the past to ask people about
what happened in the past to gather data
about what happened
and that was generally the attitude for
most of the social sciences into a
engine rooms it was a search for death
and we were concerned with actors if we
talk about memory we talked about memory
as a curse how accurate was this memory
how could we test for the accuracy how
could you look at the interview in such
a ways to understand how the interaction
undermine if we were interested in
interpretation the interpretation rested
with the interviewer historian people
were would provide us with information
and the interpretation would be ours the
power dynamic was was in that sense
monopolistic that the power rested with
the historian who would collect the data
and then interpret now there were a
couple of people who raised the question
well maybe when people tell their
histories they're already interpreting
and maybe that's the first
interpretation saw medicine yeah if you
read the essay in the night there was an
attitude that the interviewer was
withdrawn and people were subjects of
the interviewer and the interviewer was
contemplating there was a distance
relationship we talked about the portly
sure but it was always how to manipulate
that report in order to gain accurate
night
about what happened in the past so there
was the relationship was an unequal
relationship and a distance relationship
in the 1970s for any number of reasons
and we can get it if you want to talk
about the songs are having to do with
the experience of younger people coming
in from field some of the great many of
them having to do with how the new left
found history of concern with culture
cultural history number of people talk
about oral history is different what
makes history the different what the
deeper structure of that interview was
and how it was created in a biological
process in a process there was a joint
creation my first call that a shared
authority but there was a different way
of looking at the or examining it as a
text not only were very interested in
finding out what happened in the past
we're interested in how people organize
their histories of the next how people
put together their stories we became
interested in story and became
interested in memory in a different way
and from cultural history that we picked
up on memory as construction not memory
as accuracy but memory as construction
how do people now recreate a story or
create a story about what happened to
that so we became concerned with
narrative how do you analyze the
narrative do we look at a narrative
structurally do we look at our narrative
deserves the historical patterns of
narrative how do we understand this
person who is telling us this story so
that we can further understand the
historical imagination at play and in
these this is what I mean by the
transformation it's a different way of
looking at the interview and that's what
that essay is attempting to do in its
own way to kind of open it up to you if
any of you have questions a week in
Philly and on about that transformation